Hello, and welcome
to this episode
of The VizDev Art School.
My name is Ryan Meinerding.
I'm the head of Visual
Development at Marvel Studios.
I sort of spend my days
drawing and painting the Marvel
characters for the MCU.
This series of
instructional videos,
we're going to start
just talking about how
to do some drawing and painting,
how to draw the characters
and give you guys a chance to
sort of draw along with us.
As well as, hopefully
at the end of it,
giving you something
that you can print out
and color in if you want to.
Drawing and painting is one of
those great joys in my life,
and it's one of those
things that hopefully
you guys can be inspired to
do, and so let's get drawing.
All right.
Let's get started
drawing and talking
about drawing these characters.
So what type of character
are you trying to draw?
Usually breaks down
very simply for comics
into heroes or villains.
And then once you've
answered that question,
what type of hero are they, or
what type of villain are they?
There's lots of different
types of heroes.
You think of the
difference between the Hulk
and Captain America, Iron Man.
Are they strong?
Are they fast, intelligent?
What type of villain are they?
You know, there are lots of
different types of villains
as well.
And one of the things
with Super Heroes
is you have that great idea of
like, what are their powers?
And you combine
all of those things
together into a pose, posture,
expression, and design.
And let's, you know, each
one of those categories
could really take an
entire course of discussion
to talk about, but let's
start with poses with heroes.
Most poses that we try to work
out have a lot of inherently
heroic characteristics.
We're trying to make
chests feel strong,
and shoulders feel strong and
have the gesture of the pose
really make the
character feel powerful.
Whether that's a running pose,
a standing pose, or a flying
pose, or a jumping pose.
But most of the time where we
are trying to find strength
is sort of an inherent
part of being a Super Hero,
and we're usually
trying to find ways
of making each character's
unique strengths
visible in their poses.
When I do Captain
America poses, I'm
usually trying to find
ways of making him
feel heroic and noble as well.
A lot of times that
translates into, you know,
looking off into the distance.
Sometimes it is about
a very specific type
of expression, which we
can talk about expressions
in a little bit.
When it's Iron Man, he
has great flying poses,
but he also is a very strong
fighter and has the chest RT,
so anytime you can
emphasize those types
of unique individualistic
characteristics
of each character, that's
one of the important points.
Another one is, if
you're going to fly,
how are they going to fly?
You know, Iron Man
needs his repulsors
in order to fly, so how does
a character with repulsors
fly differently than a character
like Captain Marvel who
doesn't, or Doctor
Strange, who requires
the Cloak of Levitation?
But the main point about this
is to define poses as sort
of different than postures.
Postures are essentially,
it's very simple.
A pose is basically something
that any character can achieve,
you know, they can throw
a punch, they can run.
A posture is essentially
what is the basic gesture
of the character that's
baked into that character?
So the Hulk here-- for
example on the left--
has more of a hunched
over posture and something
would be more like Captain
Marvel on the right
has more of a sort of
like a strong gesture
of a proud gesture of
sticking her shoulders back.
There's lots more we could
say about poses and postures,
but moving on to expressions so
they can get cover all these,
you know, fairly quickly.
I'm sort of just drawing
a base face here,
and in order to put
expressions on top of,
usually this is
the way that I'll
test out different
expressions on characters.
If we're doing a unique
character design like Thanos
or the Hulk, we'll
do a neutral face,
and then we'll do
expressions on top,
and I'm just doing a
sort of generic male face
and then a generic female face.
A lot of the structure of
these types of drawings
can come from, you know, you can
look at any number of sources
in the comics as reference.
There's also great
instructional books
from Andrew Loomis that talk
about different structures
of the face.
Bridgman is another
great artist that
did great instructional
books on figure drawing
and, you know, but
generally speaking, it's
about trying to find a
personality or character
within each face that
you draw and make
it look like that character's
looking back at you.
Once I have these heads
more or less to a place
where they're reasonable,
I'll start doing expressions.
So the first one I'm
going to do for him
was more of an anger expression.
Dropping the brows
a little bit, it's
making the eyes
squint a little bit
and turning the
mouth downwards so it
has more of a scowl to it.
There are easy ways to
get expressions to read.
Smiles, time to turn
the mouth upward,
which is maybe an obvious
one, but the notion
of adding smile lines as well
as making the eyes a little bit
squinty.
Basically, people smile
with their eyes a lot.
They also relax their
eyebrows sometimes
and get more of a ball
of a cheek on their face.
And now into surprise.
Eyebrows go up,
the eyes get wider,
so we essentially
have, you can see
more of the whole
circle of the iris
and some white of the
eye above the iris.
And into sadness, which is
raising the brows in the center
and then having that sort
of upturned line coming off
of the top of the eye
as well, and usually
the mouth is a downturned one.
And then getting into--
since we're doing Super Heros--
the notion of an extreme focus,
rage, anger fighting.
More of an extreme expression.
Having the mouth be open
and revealing the teeth
and seeing black on
either side of the teeth.
Really squinting the eyes,
dropping the brows quite a bit.
But usually, you know, all that
is filtered through looking
at these different expressions.
What's the pose your
character is doing,
and what are they
supposed to be thinking?
And how can you
make that thought
evident and basically their
posture pose and expression.
The final category that we're
talking about-- and again, each
one of these could really--
you could take a whole course
on each one of these elements.
Design is where they can meet--
can apply most to anything.
In this case, what
I'm talking about
is essentially
the core structure
of a design of a face and
then Captain America's helmet,
which is what we're going
to do when we actually get
into drawing a posed figure.
Doing a base circle
and then dropping
sort of a rectangle
down for the jaw,
and then drawing
a center line is
an important part
of drawing a face,
because knowing which side--
how far apart the eyes are,
being able to judge the whole
face together.
Throwing the helmet on top,
I'm also looking for lines
that always point back to
the eyes, and the ridges
on his helmet as well as the A
both point to his eyes, which
are very useful design
tools, but we're
usually trying to find
a stronger jaw line
and sort of very useful--
I think the word strong
and strength has come up
a couple of times when I've
been talking about this,
and since they are
Super Heroes, we're
trying to find those
types of strong qualities
in the jaw line and
in the head shape.
So I'm going to start drawing
an actual posed character now.
This is going to be a
drawing of Captain America.
Usually starting with
that circle again
and then dropping
down the rectangle
and chiseling it into
a triangle for the jaw,
finding the center line,
and then drawing the brows
and the mouth on top of it.
The triangle that comes
down from the cheekbones
down to the mouth is an
important set of lines
as well, because it really
defines that front plane
as strongly as possible.
You know, when you get
into drawing characters
and faces like
this, you're trying
to find the most simple
not only two dimensional
read for characters, but
also the three dimensional
read that triangle
of the cheekbones
that come down to the mouth is
an important and useful tool.
So after having had a basic
understanding of the Captain
America helmet from
the front view,
I'm now trying to
recreate it in a 3/4,
and drawing the head first
is an important tool for me,
especially with Cap's
head, because he's
a unique character.
Not a totally unique
character, but you know,
you have a character like
Spider-Man whose faces is
entirely covered with a mask.
Cap's head is, you
know, you see his eyes
and you see his mouth
and nose, but then you
have to also design the
helmet over top of it,
or draw the helmet
over top of it.
And I usually have to
draw as strong of a head
as I can on his actual,
you know, for his face,
and then I draw
the helmet on top,
because if I try to just
draw them at the same time,
it never seems to work.
Getting in there and
detailing out some of the,
you know, the iris, and
the pupil, and eyelashes.
A lot of that stuff really does
help in defining the character
and in making them feel
a little bit alive.
Reinforcing the jawline, the
chin strap on Captain America
is one of the most helpful
design elements for his face,
because it really
does give him a really
strong jawline from all angles.
Actually overemphasizes
his jawline.
Now I'm getting
down into the body.
You know, trying to figure
out how to make his shoulders
feel broad, thinking
about design as well as
the straps on his
shoulders point
back to his head, which
is always a great thing.
Thinking of the rib
cage as a big egg
and sort of building all the
design lines off of that.
And also with Super
Heroes, the sort of V
that comes up off of the stripes
and into his chest and pec
shape.
It goes out to his shoulders.
It's one of those things that's
just inherent in almost every
Super Hero, you know, trying to
find a way to make their chest
feel strong and their
shoulders feel strong.
And then all these
little details on top
are basically trying to make
him feel as real as possible.
You know, thinking of Cap as
a soldier having sort of gear
and pouches on his belt to be
able to go into battle with,
and doing his iconic shield.
Maybe I'll do a specific
art school class
about drawing his
shield, because it seems
like it should be
easy, but it's not
as easy as it seems sometimes.
Drawing the legs and finding
folds that make it feel
like he has weight on his legs.
Angling the shield
a little bit more
to really echo the
gesture of his arm,
and you know, finishing off
the sketch version of his arm.
And I'm trying to add
a little bit of smoke
in the background to
just heighten the notion
of what this image is.
Him sort of maybe
hearing a call to action
and turning to see
what's happening
in a dramatic situation.
And now since I have
essentially dropped the opacity
on that sketch, and I'm
drawing over top of it
to find cleaner lines.
So it's basically the idea of
creating an underlay drawing
that then you can go and
put nicer lines on top of,
because you don't have
to specifically worry
about the placement
of everything.
It's in sort of
figured out for you.
That's one of the ways that I
do work a lot is figuring out
using rough sketches
to figure out the poses
and what's happening.
The pose, the posture and
expression, and the design,
and then going back over it
with sort of cleaner lines,
or in some cases, a full
on Photoshop painting
in order to really make the
image feel like it's real.
But a lot of this is finding the
more specific and unique design
elements of Cap, which
is a lot of things
on his costume are, you know,
tied into the star shape.
Even the design of his
stripes have become sort
of nestled into the star
shape, and most of those lines,
you know, really
emphasizing the strong V
quality in his body to try
and make him feel strong.
I always enjoyed putting seams
and things on these costumes
to try and make them feel a
little bit more real and more
structured and making
them feel like they
had been engineered for battle.
You know, if you look at
design for military clothing,
a lot of the time those things
have lots and lots of seams
on them, reinforced
seams to really make sure
that if a soldier's in
battle that that costume is
not going to be the thing
that falls apart for them.
And then I'm going in and
sort of trying to figure out,
so I'm just going to
look for the clouds.
If I get a chance to really
finish this off at some point,
I might do some better lines
and better design shapes
for clouds.
But I was getting in the
details on Cap's head
and trying to figure
out like, what's
the best way to represent this.
Ideally what I'm going
to try to do here
is create an image that you
guys can download and print
out and color in if you'd like.
So I don't want to fill in
everything, because I don't
want to take away the
possibility from you
guys coloring it, but I do feel
like Cap's helmet is pretty
dark, so I might as well just
fill in that a little bit
so that it becomes
a focal point,
and you know, you end up being
able to see him a little bit.
And because his turtle neck is
a little dark, that as well.
Also adding little hatch
marks in different places.
You know, Cap is one of these
characters who's almost,
you know, from the minute
he starts fighting,
he's a little bit dirty.
He gets, you know, dirt on
his face and different scuff
marks on his costume
and his shield,
and that is an important
part of his design as well.
So I think there's a couple of
ways you can treat this video.
I think you can treat it as if
you'd like to try and give it
a shot of using it as
an instructional video
to try and draw your own
version of Captain America,
but you can also take the
drawing that's been done
and print it out and
color it in if you'd like.
I'm just adding the sort
of finishing touches.
More again, more
scuffs and scrapes,
and adding some additional
details to the shield.
And I think that's
pretty much the final.
I hope you've
enjoyed this version
of The VizDev Art School.
I hope you guys
have a great day.